one of the things that I think is
depressed me most about our political
system in the last decade or so has been
the incredible partisanship there's
nothing wrong with people fighting about
issues and having different views about
them and arguing vigorously for that
point of view but opposing a point of
view simply because it's trying to view
of the other party right that's bad
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal and they
are endowed by their career a certain
unalienable Rio but not right slot for
the leaving person unless they're
American in their wat and they have a
lot of money those are my moral
values we don't have to do anything but
look right there and see how far
tomorrow's have dropped in this country
do we
you can actually see Russia from land
here in Alaska you cannot go to a
7-eleven our dunkin donuts unless you
have a slight indian accent to pull a
joke
we're headed towards 20 30 years of
incredible chaos and turmoil
on Iraq on the economy on healthcare on
global warming there's no real issue
where the parties agree me the
distinctions are huge
Barack Obama needs to return to Illinois
in the Senate and get some experience
and get out and live in the real world
for a few years and get out of that
elitist Conclave they called Barack
Obama and elitist and they pretended to
Republicans on their side Cindy McCain
her heartwarming story when she was a
kid is she helped her dad pick out a
several hundred thousand dollar fountain
in front of their mansion John McCain
spurned one establishment but ended up
ironically embracing the other which is
the cultural conservatives no question
about it the Republican Party
understands better what's in the Bible
than the Democratic Party they
demonstrate it better yes there's no
reason to kill an unborn baby God
wouldn't want that Republicans wouldn't
want that and Democrats want that um it
seems like it is John McCain like he's a
real guy you know he's had a real life
don't think he eats a robot I seem to do
the hot dogs and hamburgers ain't
arugula this is the Huffington Post
oasis lounge this is a chocolate
smoothie letting healthy Chavez moving
fast soy milk a raw organic fairtrade
cacao powder
everything that's happening out in the
world today is happening because there's
a sense of an us-against-them on this
sense of other news you guys are under
attack and you're responding with
kindness it doesn't work you're in the
heat of battle to win this race above
all Obama needs a sword to shield the
shield which is secondary is to fend off
with vigor and strength the attacks but
the most important thing is the sword
stand up stand up stand up and fight
you
Newark is based on ideas we have enough
intelligence now to remove radical
poverty in all parts of the world the
trick for the future is to find ways to
recreate what used to be called the
Vital center one question I think it's
always useful to us is if I am so sure
I'm right how come she's so sure she's
right too there's always the possibility
to make change
the big part of democracy is being the
leader yourself
you